bonsoir monsieur est mort bonsoir
Monsieur Filion vous avez dit
aujourd'hui à la fin de votre point de
presse il y a pas de quoi perdre le
sommeil pourquoi les Québécois ne
doivent pas s'inquiéter d'un rendement
négatif le premier depuis 2008 et d'une
baisse nette de l'actif de 18 milliards
mais il faut la regarder dans son
ensemble premièrement si on regarde ça
c'est des pertes qui sont non
matérialisées essentiellement Vasse
majorité 85% dans le portefeuille
obligataire revenu fixe des obligations
du Québec des obligations du Canada des
titres de créances simplement les garder
d'ici le échéance 3-4 ans on récupère
automatiquement notre capital deuxième
chose oui c'est difficile une hausse des
taux pour les gens quotidiens mais comme
investisseur en tout cas à travers nous
c'est maintenant un portefeuille de 130
milliards revenus fixes qui génèrent si
c'est demi 7% par année donc ça fait 8 9
milliards dans ce portefeuille-là qu'on
va accumuler maintenant donc c'est
maintenant attrayant quand on regarde
vers le futur cette année pour un
meilleur rebond dans les années
prochaines pas fait est-ce que les
technologies de l'information
est-ce que votre moindre exposition
parce que vous avez un peu reculé sur
les technologies ont sauvé la mise pour
la caisse oui d'un autre côté on en
avait pas du tout en 2020 il y en avait
peut-être 10 % dans le marché les géants
de la technologie on en a mis pour trois
quatre pour cent on n'a jamais été aussi
risqué que le marché on en a un peu pour
pas être complètement exclu quand elle
monte mais en avoir moins nous a protégé
en effet et quand je regarde vos
résultats financiers je vois les marchés
en croissance par exemple marcher en
croissance le marché croissance moins
26,7% et le marché en croissance moins
18,1%. qu'est-ce que ce secteur
qu'est-ce qui a été signé négatif dans
ces segments cette année ce qui est la
plus difficile d'être dans les marchés
en croissance on parle des marchés comme
la Chine l'un tout ça la Chine a une
année difficile on se rappellera une
politique zéro covid alors ça remontait
la dernière main quand on réouvert de
façon assez importante vers le mois de
novembre alors c'est quand même des
portefeuille qui ont bien fait sur cinq
ans mais cette année il y avait quelque
chose au niveau de la Chine avec sa
fermeture complète de l'économie de
politique très radicale du gouvernement
qui évidemment avait compliqué un peu
les choses je dirais que dans l'ensemble
c'était le principal facteur c'est un
aspect important de votre portefeuille
non la chaîne c'est quand même juste 3 %
de portefeuille global une dizaine de
milliards on a toujours eu moins que nos
paires on était très prudent on était à
distance mais je dirais c'était dans ce
portefeuille là ça représente quand même
un pourcentage plus important votre
virage dans l'immobilier se poursuit
toujours vous vous tournez davantage
vers le résidentiel étudiant résidence
pour aînée résidence partagée c'est un
virage qui nous amène où à la Caisse de
dépôt résidence pour un homme en a pas
vraiment tellement juste un petit
portefeuille
résidence partagée
c'est un grand virage qui était fait
depuis deux trois ans je te regarde
l'immobilier si on avait dans l'ordre 4
segments en dessous on avait des centres
commerciaux qui étaient le plus
important des bureaux du résidentiel de
la logistique en deux ans et demi on a
complètement inversé la logistique du
résidentiel du commercial et du bureau
et ça explique les rendements qu'on a
battu nos indices de façon importante on
n'est pas loin de 70 transactions pour
des dizaines de milliards de dollars
alors c'est un revirement dans un
contexte difficile que porter fruit
rapidement de moins en moins dans les
centres commerciaux de moins en moins on
en a ceci dit on est revenu au niveau
des loyers de pré pandémie le trafic est
revenu après toute façon n'est plus
tellement sur les centres commerciaux
dans le moins ce qu'on a envolé
revitaliser c'est plus le secteur du
bureau qui est en vigie mais ici on est
en avance on est prudent mais un peu
plus de travail à faire c'est le secteur
du bureau depuis trois ans là qui porte
un peu plus inquiétude les bureaux sont
vides au centre-ville après 25-30% de
retour nous édifices qu'on a c'est le
double de ça on a des bons édifices qui
arrivent dans le bureau c'est les bons
bureaux les moins bons bureaux il y a
vraiment un prépondérance vers le flight
to Safet comme on dit mais en même temps
de ce côté-là c'est pas la même chose
qui est centres commerciaux qui est
toute à travers le Canada avait le même
enjeu le bureau c'est édifice paridifice
une note donc on vient d'aborder
plusieurs des saignements d'activités de
la Caisse de dépôt est-ce que vous
diriez que c'est
circonstanciel que la que la chute de
2022 ou au contraire nous sommes entrés
dans une ère particulièrement et
certaine avec la guerre qui se poursuit
avec les changements politiques partout
dans le monde avec les changements
climatiques puis avec certaines
inquiétudes aussi sur la reprise à
savoir si ça va être en 2023 2024 ou
même un peu plus tard je vais vous
donner trois points de mesure si on
regarde les trois dernières années on
est dans une situation un peu hors
normes depuis trois ans depuis septembre
2020 je vais rassurer les gens nos
actifs au début de la pandémie à 340
milliards sont au-delà de 400 milliards
on est 60 milliards plus élevés
oui mais surtout à cause du rendement
les dépôts c'était assez mineur dans
l'ensemble donc c'est surtout du
rendement 95%. donc la pension des gens
était pas à risque avant la pandémie
trois ans plus tard malgré toutes ces
crises là aucun enjeu je regarde aussi
la photo 31 décembre c'est une photo 402
milliards mais tellement eu de
volatilité en 2002 2022 une des années
les plus volatiles de l'histoire 15
jours avant les actifs à 10 milliards
plus élevés qu'un jour après 15
milliards plus élevé
où est-ce que ça nous amène évidemment
pour 2023 ça va être selon moi une année
aussi exigeante que 2022 il va se passer
une ou deux choses les tours vont devoir
monter encore un peu pour tempérer
l'inflation ou avoir un ralentissement
économique à cause du remède de la
hausse des taux dans les deux cas pour
les marchés des ventes alors quand
François trein qui était sur notre
plateau en début de semaine stratège à
Wall Street depuis 25 ans qui nous dit
le pire est à venir est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord je pense qu'on a encore n'est
pas sorti de l'auberge on a une année de
transition devant nous avant que le
marché trouve son équilibre parce
qu'évidemment ce qu'on a fait en 2022
aux autos a touché les multiples
d'évaluation des entreprises
en 2023 ça va être comment c'est aux
autocollants affectent les profits des
entreprises qui est la deuxième
composante donc oui il y a encore devant
nous là avant de face assez importante
dans les infrastructures vous misez sur
les énergies renouvelables vous êtes
bien positionné la long terme là-dessus
transport collectif vous avez reculé sur
le règne de l'Est mais vous avancez sur
le rhum de l'Ouest est-ce que le REM de
l'Ouest
est encore une carte de visite pour
laquelle de dépôt pour faire des projets
semblables ailleurs dans le monde oui
est-ce qu'il y a beaucoup d'intérêts
pour ce projet-là vous savez puis à
l'ouverture là il va être au printemps
en 2023 donc on va finir par le voir les
gens ont pour le constater
mais parfois il y a des gens qui le
testent alors ça ça en vient oui c'est
une carte de visite extraordinaire rien
comme montré le projet ceci dit notre en
phase notre focus est vraiment sur
offrir un service fiable à la hauteur
des attentes des usagers avant de
commencer à faire plein de projets à
travers le monde on a déjà eu des
discussions puis l'autre côté il y a des
projets à faire ici au Québec de ce côté
là on exclut pas l'international mais
vraiment c'est de mettre ce rêve là en
marche pour les gens pour les Québécois
dans les prochains mois est-ce que c'est
fini les crypto monnaie oui
à tout jamais oui pourquoi
mais je pense que il faut le regarder un
peu Celsius premièrement c'est pas un
bon investissement la personne qui est
content de ça à la caisse l'autre côté
les intentions étaient bonnes vous savez
en capital de risques et toujours à la
thèse une transformation d'une
entreprise une première entrée trop tôt
dans un secteur en émergence une
compagnie qui en avait identité des
choses à transformer mais il y en avait
trop on a fait notre travail mais il y
avait un plan qui restait avec notre
partenaire inachevé parce qu'avec la
chute brutale des crypto mais ça va
entraîné cette crise là de liquidité
puis le plan est resté inachevé donc
dans ce contexte là les intentions ta
bonne mais la décision s'est avéré
finalement non fructueuse et donc vous
prenez la décision aujourd'hui nous ne
plus jamais investir dans les
crypto-monnaies non pas directement puis
vous savez je pense qu'on apprend là
dedans on tire les leçons et puis c'est
du capital de risque c'est une exception
dans un portefeuille qui a fait
extrêmement bien pour les Québécois 20
25% de rendement dans les cinq dernières
années alors il faut quand même le
situer dans ce contexte là est-ce que un
an de guerre on s'est parlé c'était la
guerre qui commençait l'an passé le jour
de nos résultats et là plus tard c'est
c'est le premier anniversaire est-ce que
l'Ukraine a un impact important dans les
activités dans le rendement de la Caisse
de dépôt
il y a plusieurs cercles concentrés que
l'impact de ça les chaînes
d'approvisionnement l'inflation le prix
des commodités
le géopolitique se complique malgré tout
lié à ça on voit que quand même
plusieurs pays qui jouent de façon
interposée que ce soit sur le chantier
du réel pour recevoir des pièces jusqu'à
un impact sur la performance de certains
marchés la hausse des taux l'inflation
c'est partout c'est partout oui vous
augmentez vos investissements au Québec
mais je regardais il y a 10 ans la part
d'investissement dans tout votre
portefeuille en 2012 c'était
26,7%. aujourd'hui c'est 19,5% pourquoi
la part d'investissement du Québec
baisse dans l'ensemble de votre actif
c'est un point très important que vous
mentionnez parce que pour moi c'est pas
combien qu'il y a d'actifs
nécessairement du Québec dans l'actif de
la caisse qui est la mesure pertinente
la mesure pertinente pour moi c'est
combien qu'on a 13 ans dans l'économie
du Québec c'est ça qui est la mesure
pertinente parce que sinon on mesure par
rapport à l'ensemble du monde entier ils
sont leur garde deux choses
combien qu'on a aujourd'hui il y a aucun
fonds de pension dans le monde qui est
plus investi 80 milliards dans son
économie locale dans ce cas-ci 500
milliards que nous deuxième chose sur 10
ans ce ratio là il a doublé donc il faut
prendre aussi conscience de la grosseur
de l'économie dans laquelle on va
investir la grosseur de la caisse pour
moi c'est pas la même dénominateur le
plus pertinent ceci dit il est en hausse
depuis trois ans Charlie maure merci de
nous merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir merci pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI